welcome to this video playing our spin
doors you populate them just very
recently but I've forgotten what this
was really again so let's go for this
can I go fo here already so [ __ ] that's
very ambitious but if it works out the
position is great trying to make as
bishop on c1 look a little bit silly hmm
might work out might work out so I'm
going d5 I really need to get my bishop
out some somewhere b6 is also possible
let's go be sex maybe
a palm of god's own something that i can
attack if i go down d5 now and boom
Bishop a six maybe a bishop a six
immediately was even stronger knight
Knight f3 already looks very dangerous I
come on let's play just just
strategically here nothing nothing fancy
o Knight f3 anyway Queen wants to do
wants to go on a light square anyway so
let's do that some 25 already very
dangerous mmm and let's go cunha 5
yeah even 94 is not completely
ridiculous but let's go here yeah the
second take your a 1 rook is not
protected white resign that was a
disaster yeah it was already here when
he for it's the kind of move you have to
punish immediately or otherwise your
words and he didn't do anything if i get
time to set up my night on d 395 and
then I'm great and computer gives this
move with roughly equal play like here
Teague's check a with complete with a
completely wacky position that it
assesses as 000 or typically and now now
i'm already in great shape 95 was better
but okay here the control over the light
squares is just amazing maybe I had
better moves but I wanted to to be quick
about it 27 here Knight f3 years such a
minus 3 but okay this isn't bad either
yeah and Luke is hanging also end up
threatening c5 everything at once it's
blundered the bishop yeah just an off
game MP got into this huge trouble right
in the first couple of moves and
couldn't really come back from that okay
well thanks for watching